so I'm going to ask the question that um
all four of us
is dying to really want to know
[Music]
are you perky
shotgun wedding
[Music]
's not going weird
well I mean it is awful soon
the heck
I'm pregnant
this is crazy I can't believe my family
thinks I'm getting married because I'm
pregnant
I get it and we both understand what
people here would like to come my
friends the family we made here so
that's the reason for the quick wedding
for the most part
thank God
next step is to get on birth control
save a whole lot of handshakes
no I'm talking about a whole lot of
headache no
okay
[Music]
a whole lot of Hassle and headache
I thought you said a whole lot of a
essay
I got a question asking oh those were
there
so when you
and Caleb
be hugging and kissing on each other
y'all be rubbing trikes together oh hell
no that's foreplay like this oh yeah
[Laughter]
I can't feel you what would Caleb say if
we said that to him he might pop awesome
and I might pop off something back too
hmm
I'm nervous
I just want my family to support me and
be happy for me
It's My Life
and I should get what I want
[Music]